yes
all right so uh we're very excited to
have sylvan ceron uh giving the next
talk
so um
sarcastic games and
moral are you know interesting
settings where a lot of perspectives are
coming into play we've seen a lot from
machine learning and ai
but a lot of
the
understanding of those games is founded
on
you know the mathematics of game theory
so sylvan is an expert
on this topic so we're very excited to
hear about his perspective on you know
what's going on here thank you so much
many thanks many things it's so it's a
great pleasure to be to be here
uh
i feel
a bit like a grandfather with all these
young people but
it's very nice new to pick new faces
i was there 40 years ago there was a
special year on the game theory and
mathematical economics of msri
and it's a completely new area now
and it's quite fascinating okay so
it will be
very elementary
but it's it's a slightly different
approach i want
especially to emphasize the
interest of looking at continuous time
for this kind of problems
so
i will start by
equaling no regret procedure so this is
very very elementary as i told you and
it's just to fix a notation
so
we'll start with a finite
you have a finite
set k
this is a set of action and then you
have time which is discrete
and at stage n the agent will choose
a component k n
in the set k and then he learns
this vector u n okay
and the outcome is the k n component of
the vector and the regret is u n minus
this component okay so there is no
assumption
on the reward process
and the strategy of the agent is as
usual a map from a previous history to
uh mixed action
so this is
called the external external
okay
so this is the
the choice of the adjacent u is a vector
and this is okay so uh
the evaluation of the procedure
generated by the strategy is
a strategy will be basically a path here
okay and used by the time in this set k
and the evaluation is the regret is the
comparison of the payoff along this
trajectory to the payoff on any constant
trajectory okay so you have a vector
here
and
you compare the average
actual payoff to the average payer that
will be obtained by a constant component
so you want to generate a trajectory
that will be better than all these
constant project copies this is a
version of
external regret and
we call strategy satisfies eternal
consistency so you see this is game
theoretical framework i'm speaking about
strategy and not
algorithm
if you have this property
now
internal regret is more sophisticated
it's for every specific
point here in this set
let's let's call it i you look at the
stages where you are using or predicting
this component and at these stages you
compare
the
the outcome to
any
other fixed outcome okay so what you
generate here is not a vector but
a matrix okay so this is the kl
component of the matrix is zero if you
are not choosing k and otherwise you
compare k to l
you have
the same notion of average regret
so it's com comparison for each
component of the average payoff obtained
at the date you were using a specific
choice everything is well known and
similarly you define internal
consistency
so the associated dynamics
are since you are losing looking at
average
so
you have a process zn
znbar is the average so it's defined by
this
procedure so
another way to write it is that the
difference
in the the average process is one over n
this is the
payoff at stage or the outcome at stage
n and this is the average okay
so uh this is
a
discrete time
uh
random
difference equation
and i will associate to this
continuous time deterministic
differential infusion
the way you do it is you replace
the handle variable by its conditional
expectation so this is u n
you look at all the possible value of u
n that depends on the vector that you
will observe okay so this is the set vn
okay so
you write this like this this is
included is one over n because vn is all
the set of possible value of e okay and
this will be a noise because it's
from the variable minus conditional
expectations
and then we'll compare the trajectories
of this average here to the trajectories
and used by this differential inclusion
that are
not belongs to vt minus 20.
okay
so
i think it's a nice place to recall
blackwell's theorem in fact i met
blackwell you know 40 years ago we
discussed a lot it was
i don't know
if some of you met
david blackwell at some point
he was not only a genius but he was
really a very very very nice person okay
and so
it's one of my best remembrance of
berkeley is
was this discussion with blackwell
so blackwell theorem is the following
you have a two-person
game
you can assume finite action space just
and then uh
the outcome is a vector in some location
space circuit okay
and the game is repeated at each stage
you know the past history of moves okay
and
as usual the player can choose
the extraction
okay
so a strategy is as usual play and use a
sequence of outcome in rk you look at
zebra which is the cesaro mean okay and
what is interesting in this framework is
whether you can approach a set so a set
c
so this is the set c it's you are in rk
and
the player of the game generates a
sequence of points zn zn plus one
okay and you look at the average
so
so zn bar stage okay and you say that
the set c is approachable by player 1 if
there is a strategy of this guy such
that
this
average will converge to this seat or
you can say that the expectation of the
distance will go to zero
it's excludable
by a player if
he can approach
the complement of a neighborhood existed
so the way you will use blackwell
theorem in our framework is to prove
that
if you look at the external regret the
average of
the average of the outcome will approach
the negative rk okay meaning that all
components will be negative and in
internal right you look at the matrix so
you want to approach this okay so this
is the use of approachability for
non-regret theory okay
so given
x which is a mixed strategy a
probability on this set you define x a
so x a is the convex style of the
expectation and used by the strategy x
okay
so it means that if player one play x
the the expected outcome will be
interested okay
so there are two points in blackwell
theorem one is the notion of b set and
the sufficient condition for a set to be
approachable and the second is the
specific case class of convex set so we
say that the closed set c is a b site if
for every point which is
so
for every z here you look at the closest
point
that's a new
in in c a closest part is c
to z okay and what you want is that
there is
a move a strategy of player 1 such that
the set x a is on the other side of
this hyper plane perpendicular to uc
so for every z you look at u which is
the closest point to z in c and you want
that there exists x such that the set of
expectation and used by this strategy
lies on the other
dimension okay so this is a notion of b
set okay
so
quick sorry is a script here is this
like euclidean projection no you don't
need that you don't you don't need the
oxygen it's the closest
because you may have several points okay
you may have several points that are
close it's the closest point okay yes
so uh this is this property okay this
angle is
more than
80 degrees okay
and the blackwell theorem says that if
you have a b side then it's approachable
by by this player just by using this
strategy here and this is the speed of
convergence so this is the expectation
of the distance and this is convergence
in the probability
so the crucial property
of the strategy is the contr control of
the
trajectory there is this property so
this is the average stage and this is
the closest point this is the
expectation of the next
uh
outcome
okay and this is this property here that
you have
angle
so in particular you have come as a
corollary that
x a for any x is approachable by a
player because you can generate a point
a also every alpha space containing this
point has this property
so if you look at the draw a necessary
condition for a set to be approachable
is that your opponent cannot approach
the threat with an empty intersection
with it
okay so this is obviously a necessary
condition for the set to be approachable
what is nice in this convex framework
it's a sufficient condition
okay and this is a consequence of the
mean max theorem so uh look now you are
in the in the convex framework the set c
is convex okay and what you know is that
for every y
of your opponent the set a y
okay will intersect
the set c otherwise the opponent could
exclude the set okay so now you take a
point
you look at so you take a point outside
you look at here it's a projection you
look at the hyperplane
and what you know is that
for every strategy of the opponent the
intersection with c will be non-empty so
if you look at the projection on this
line
it means that for every strategy of the
opponent player one can get a payoff on
this side okay now you use the min max
theorem
then there exists a strategy of player 1
that will force a player from this side
but it's a projection of what you can
force in the game so the x a
has to be on this side of the hyperplane
okay so this is why
in in the convex framework okay
either you have a b set or
your opponent can exclude the set okay
so there are two components in
blackboard crm one is a sufficient
condition for a set to be approachable
and the second is the analog of the mid
max theorem for convex sensor
dual version
so
given the dynamics the theta dot so it's
the first order dynamic and the set c
a sufficient condition for viability so
this goes back to nagumo in japanese
mathematicians this was done in 42 but
it was not
known because it was during the war so
it has been proved again by a lot of
mathematician and it's a condition for
viability the ability means that the
trajectory if you start in c will remain
in c
okay and the condition is like this the
scalar product p f f of this function
has to be negative for what for all p
which is approximately normal to c so
what is the proximal normal to a set you
look at the set
okay so you will see that the proximal
normal if you are at the entire reduced
to zero and otherwise if you are at the
boundary here so you take a point theta
on the boundary and
approximate normal is a vector p
such as starting from theta if you add p
then this
the circle
or the disk center at theta plus p
intersection with c is reduced to theta
okay
so p is a set of direction such that the
closest point from theta plus b to the
statistic
okay
yes
this property of viability extends to
differential equation
and you have these properties so if you
have a differential equation a condition
for invariance meaning that all strategy
all solution of the differential
inclusion will remain in the set is this
and now i claim that this is exactly
what we have here because remember that
if you have a b set it means that
this is the property for every y there
is an x subject for every y yes you have
this this super particular but you see
this was a projection from z to u okay
so if you forget and you start from u
this is a vector p
okay so block wave strategy is starting
from outside look at the closest point
and you want to be on this side okay
says this the other thing you are inside
you look at the point on the boundary
you look at the proximal map and you
want to stay here okay so it's exactly
the environment's condition for the
differential exclusion where v
corresponds to the actual payoff at
stage t and theta assist okay
so
this explains that blackwell condition
or nagumo's condition of the ability
conditions are the same
now how do you get uh how did you get
approachability it's starting from any
point outside you mimic the behavior if
you are starting inside starting inside
you know that there is a strategy that
will remain inside because you have
viable okay and then since both have the
same v the difference is you have data
one here that are one e and the same v
so the difference will have uh
exponential convergence okay so the
strategy tattoo the trajectory that will
remain in c
and the difference between the strategic
the strategy trajectory data one and
theta two goes to zero so this explains
that you have
approachability okay
so basically approachability and
variance appears as good notion okay the
first correspond to an exterior
viewpoint you are outside and you want
to register and the second means that
you are inside and you want to stay
outside okay
and
this is what i want to say concerning
backwards so let us prove convergence of
the hog right
for black
using black right there here we don't
need all the
the strong form of
approachability or b set because the
regret our specific
uh
structure okay and also we want to
approach not
any set not any convex set but an
orchard which has a very very specific
structure so there is two property of
the rigor that will be used
for external regret remember the regret
is a random variable depending on your
choice k
u is the vector you don't know
so
assume that you take a mixed strategy a
probability on k and you look at the
expectation of
the regret forever you like you'll take
the scalar product with x
because this is always zero okay it
means that the basically the
the distance to the mean in expectation
is zero okay so this is quite quite
standard and you have a similar property
for internal regrets
you have to be careful because italian
regret is now in r
it's it's a matrix okay so you cannot
use directly a probability on k so what
you do is that when you have a matrix
with nonnegative coefficient it defines
a set of invariant measures which are
the
probability on case satisfying this okay
this is
basically if a is of a chain this this
other regular invariant measure if you
have
a matrix with no negative coefficient
it's the same proof which is by the way
the consequence of the mean maximum
and then what you have is
remember this is the matrix of internal
regret it's also random
variable you choose k according to mu
okay you take the expectation of this
matrix you take the scalar product with
a this is what the
matrix you start with and you get zero
which is a consequence of this
okay
so these are the properties that we'll
use to prove black white theory
now this was the part on the rig right
now this is the part on the set remember
that the set is an orton so i i say that
p is the potential for the outcome is
it's a c1 function it's zero on the
negative vertex the gradient is always
positive and the scalar product is
positive when i'm not
this was introduced
well i there are a lot of references i
should have have
mentioned okay right right start with
anand and then with blackwell this
notion of potential function for their
tent was introduced by art and masculine
and now
you have
the proof of black white theorem is
quite simple you take a potential p
okay and the p external great base
discrete procedure is just
if if the the average regret is already
in the earth
you do whatever you want otherwise you
take a mixed strategy which is
proportional to the gradient remember
that the gradient has all component
positive and is not zero so this is well
defined the discrete dynamic is this you
look at
the conditional expectation here you
forget about the average term and the
choice of sigma remember the produce
equality x expectation with respect to x
of the regret is zero but x here is
proportional to the gradient so you have
this property
okay so the continuous version of this
can be written as this is w dot
the average
value here of the expectation is the
correspondence n of the value
and here you have the term w
so the continuous version of this is
this okay but now uh what i know about
the values here this is this property
the gradient time n is zero okay
so as a consequence you get that the
potential p is the happiness function
associated to c
why but you look at here you take the
derivative to evaluate p on the
trajectory
you have the gradient time double dot
w dot belongs to n of w minus w this
scalar product is zero this was a
produce and this is negative okay so you
have this property okay so this proves
the convergence in a continuous time
okay and now the convergence in discrete
time follows for property of stochastic
approximation okay so the fact that you
can replace the random variable by the
conditional expectation and
that you have this opportunity
what is nice here is that it's exactly
exactly the same proof for the internal
regret
okay rather than taking the gradient you
look at an invariant measure for the
gradient you remember that the gradient
is a positive matrix
you look at some invalid measure you
have this recursive formula for the
internal root matrix the same property
here now this is a product of matrices
okay so uh you have exactly the same
property with the new
with the new uh potential
okay so this is the use of blackwell
theorem to prove uh
the
fact that the internal or external
normal rate vanishes
okay
okay so uh now remember that uh the
total regret was this this was a rounded
variable i will replace this is the
random variable corresponding to my
choice i replace it by the conditional
expectation okay and the difference
is a banded martingale difference i use
often as you must say concentration
inequality to reduce the analysis to
this okay so rather than looking at the
random variable i take here the
conditional expectation
they are the extreme point i can replace
by any point x and then i get this
notion of forgot which is the usual
regret that you are working working is
with
except that here it's on delta k okay
but then you get rid of this and
more generally we have the this this
approach okay so uh v is enormous vector
space i will always assume it's finite
dimensional
and the t v star and delete map so
meaning that it's not necessarily
accident framework okay so i can have
all this validity map here and i will
assume here x to be compact convex
in game if you don't have compactness
then
it's difficult to get a cuber
so in continuous time i will do not now
by u.s the
capital u.s the debater and this is
the regret and the novel that property
is nice
so we'll compare the performance of the
algorithm in terms of fraud fragrance
where there are three different
assumptions so general case you don't
make any assumption about this vector ut
then what is called the closed form ut
is the function of what you are doing
okay and the convex gradient is when ut
is minus the gradient of a complex
function and then i will recall
protected dynamics via
the samsung and approaching
and
first a few remarks concerning the
closed form and variation and
inequalities so it means that here the
vector u is actually a function of your
choice okay for a continuous vector
field defined on nice so it's it's
especially interesting in the cam
in the framework of of games okay
and uh
so this was mentioned by uh
by ella azan okay uh
when you look when you work in games
okay the nice
parameter
is not the player function
it's the way you write equilibrium
condition
and you want to write the keyboard
condition as variational inequalities
and the function that appears in this
variational inequality that will play
the fundamental role in the learning
process
okay
so you want to write
nash
you want that the equilibrium set is
given by a set of this okay where a
capital x is the set of structure player
i okay so here
this is the relevant variable for player
i x is the n tuple of choice by all the
player and this is the choice of player
i and an alternative
alternative choice
so the basic example where you have this
is the obviously finite games
in final games phi i is just the waiter
payoff and x by the move of the player
so you give you are given the the
strategy of the opponent and you look at
the collection of payoff and used by
your own strategy okay this is the vapor
payoff okay and nash equilibrium
more interesting is continuous game with
vector payoff okay so you assume that
it's c1 and concave with respect to your
own variable and then phi is the
gradient of your payoff is obvious to
your own variable
okay
yes so to say that
say that
your payoff okay
is greater than any alternative payoff
if you change your strategy since your
your function is concave in c1 can be
can be written
through a linear inequality on the
gradient
okay and this is the special crucial
part okay but now if you look at
population gain or group
or
games okay
x i is the same place so
now
a point here will correspond to a
fraction of the population which is
using each of the strategy okay and then
the
the vector field is simply the player
function
okay so depending on the time type of
game the the
the right parameter that you use okay to
describe nashiki we are is not the same
okay and this is this parameter that is
the one that
is
important in the learning procedure
so for each player the reference process
is fired of xt which depends on the
the behavior of all players but the the
the trajectory of player i is not a
function of the fee
j of the other player okay it's not a
function of the
evaluation of the
okay so
well this is clear that if each
if each
each player you have the no reward
condition then obviously for the general
process you have the same conditionals
okay now
the connection with via challenge
inequalities
so this is the one i start with and i
will call it the nice equilibrium for
phi okay and then there is a dual uh
inequality where you replace e
x by y
okay so it's
why i call it a set of external
solutions okay
the existence here of solution if phi is
continuous is the consequence of our
theorem
this may have no solution
but the set of solutions may be empty
but it's always convex
what is interesting is that if the
vector field is dissipative meaning that
you have this property is anti-monotonic
okay
then we say that the game is dissipative
okay and there is a theorem of minty
saying that in this case
the set
s e is not empty and
set of nash equilibria is increments
it's the same that
oh
yeah
okay external solution okay so if phi is
continuous okay and you satisfy this
then you satisfy this
if phi is dissipative and you satisfy
this your statistics
okay moreover if phi is dissipative the
proof that this set is not empty is a
consequence of the minmak theorem
okay so in terms of complexity it's very
interesting okay if you have a general
continuous function this might be empty
this is not empty if phi has this
monotonicity requirement this is not
empty okay it's including this okay and
the fact that this is not empty can be
proved using the mean max theorem okay
and
this is basically what uh
explain the result concerning uh
concerning the convergence of this
algorithm and the fundamental example of
a dissipative vector field is
a zero sub game so you have a function
from the product space and you look so
it's concave convex and the vector field
is the gradient with respect to the
first component minus the gradient with
respect to the second and this is
dissipative okay so the basic example of
a dissipative vector field is a zero-sum
game
but you may have
okay and now uh two property assume that
you have a procedure that satisfies the
no regret property it means that this is
a little of t
okay it continues for discrete time
first of all if the trajectory converge
then it will convert to a nash
equilibrium or to a solution of any okay
because you have this
this converts to phi of x this converges
to x divided by t this goes to zero
okay
so uh then you take the average all this
term converts to phi of t so you have
this okay so this is negative okay
in particular if you have a stationary
point then it's an equilibrium
on the other and if you look at time
average trajectory if phi is dissipative
the accumulation point of the average
are in sc
and the point is that you use here the
fact it's monotonic to replace xs here
you see here you cannot take any average
you don't have any linearity on phi you
don't know anything about five but you
replace here by phi of y and here this
is linear
okay and this is this is the proof okay
so what you get here is that if you know
that there are no regret algorithm then
you can prove directly that the there
are solutions to se because any
accumulation point will be a solution
okay and this is one of the
simplest proof of all this mean
but this is this is well known
okay so uh this was just a
sorry
last point level function application
i'm looking at the continuous time
formulation i would say that a function
with positive value is a level function
if you have this property it's okay so
it depends on the ut and your trajectory
xt so it depends on the on the algorithm
and i want this property here
ut xt minus y greater than this
now if there is a level function then
the the ring weight which is the
integral of this is smaller than p of
zero minus p of t p of t is positive so
it's bounded so the the rate of
convergence of the quick weight is one
over t
and if
you are in the closed form and y star is
in s e
then
d of dt of p1 is given by this y star is
in sc so this project is negative so it
means that this is a negative this is
the happiness function p of t of y star
is the equation okay
so
this you can use for three dynamics
projected dynamics this is the projected
guardian descents in discrete time you
look at the continuous time
analogous okay
which is given by this property here so
ut is the process that you will discover
xt is the process that you generate and
this is the characterization
and the claim is that there is a level
function which is just the distance here
okay so you just look at the derivative
here and you have this property
so this implies first that
the regret goes to zero with the right
one over chip two that this is
decreasing when you take a point a star
y star in sc
okay and this implies convergence of the
trajectory using uh
using opiate flavor
you know that this converges
okay and you know that the accumulation
point of the average are in esse so this
implies that you have convergence of the
trajectory
for mirror descent you look at the
continuous time the continuous time
version of neural descent so here you
take a stretch of like c2 function
you look at the breakdown distance
associated to this function
and the nearest algorithm discrete time
is given by this okay
with this variational formulation you go
to the continuous time you have this
continuously formulation
the previous case corresponds to one
half of the norm and then you have a
level function
so
the
divergence
associated to y and x t is a level
function so this implies immediately
that you have convergence of the regret
whatever
okay and finally for dwell averaging
which is the continuous version of the
leicester of the region here you assume
that h is bonded strictly convex where
the domain is x okay
you look at the french conjugate this is
in discrete time
okay
where you have a step size the
continuous time analysis
is this
x t is the gradient
of the french conjugate vt is
the cumulative payoff okay and then that
you have that
this wt which is a star of vt plus h1 so
it's it's a
factual difference okay
as
this
property okay d of detailed with it so
it's a level function okay
so
again you have this property of the
regret
so you have analogous properties in
discrete time and
you have correction term which is a
function of the step size and you have
no regularity
on the penalty function you want the
function not only to be strictly convex
but strongly convex but otherwise it's
basically the same id i'm sorry i'm too
late
i wanted to say something about
correlation and potential game but i
will keep it for discussion
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you silver for a very
insightful uh talk um
unfortunately my computer died of
battery so
i didn't monitor the questions over
there
the last thing i saw was uh
drew fundenberg who was online said that
he had met blackwell
and he was a very nice guy
he and also he recommended him to go to
the library and read a lot of novels
that's the last thing i saw on the chat
but uh
are there any in the like uh if you're
on if you're on the zoom call and you
have a question please speak up because
i unfortunately didn't see your question
uh uh otherwise i can start with the
questions in the room
uh let me start with one that i have so
uh silva you talked about uh dissipative
uh games yeah and uh just to connect a
little bit i mean like to the also to
like uh
multi-agent reinforcement learning
and say for example you know like uh
two-player zero-sum
uh you know stochastic games so these
are not uh dissipative but do you know
you know
there is some recent work uh
on games that are close to being
dissipative like you know like this
up to some error and so on so forth
where
you know like maybe not all no regret
learning algorithms converge but like
some if you if you if you know if you
okay so
two points yeah one about stochastic
games so
i'm very excited by all this uh work on
on stochastic game uh but i have a
question
the question is that optimal strategy in
stochastic game refer to
some
basically discontent stochastic
okay it's not a one-stage game okay so
when you say that the strategy will
converge from optimal strategy what is
the meaning because you are not going to
play the game once and again and again
and again okay so it's along the play of
the game that the strategy will converge
but since the game is discounted when
the strategy will converge the game is
over yeah like stationary let's say in
stationary markov policies
yes very well but you use your
stationary policy in the game okay the
game is discounted
if you are close to an optimal strategy
and well then uh but okay fine so uh
uh
[Music]
well
[Music]
let's just view the you know the
stochastic game as a function the player
function as a function of two a pair of
stationary type of policies
uh you know you can look at the gradient
the policy gradient respectively yeah
yeah
so
[Music]
the point is that when you are close to
uh and you are not uh exactly but this
may this may have a lot of
consequences okay and the typical
example is you are close to potential
gain but you are no longer again okay
in terms of that in terms of attractors
in terms of everything you have uh
continuity so if you have another factor
it will still be an attractor okay but
in terms of uh uh equilibrium it may be
completely completely different okay so
the typical the basic example of this is
majority
you have three rooms uh two rooms and
three players okay and you have one if
you are the only one in your room and
otherwise
you get zero okay so you have three
players okay and
here there are three players in the same
room so this is not bad the same the
three players are in the same room this
is not bad but otherwise you get this is
okay
so this set here which is on the rough
into a circle is a set of nasher cables
where you put two players in a room and
one in the other okay and then if you
are two in a room you can go to the
other room okay you don't care so this
is why the set of nashikiri where is the
memory to the circle okay and it's a
potential game so there is another
aquarium we have where it will be choose
a condom it's in the middle okay and now
if you have a potential game all these
dynamics will increase the potential
okay so basically the attractor will be
in the neighborhood of this set of
equilibrium
yes
now if you have these three players and
rather than being indifferent of being
with one of the other they have
preferences one wants to be with two and
one and two will want to be with three
okay all these nash equilibrium
disappeared
because each time you put two person in
a room and one in the other one of the
two will prefer to be there and the guy
will change
okay so whatever being the preference it
can be upside us okay what you get is
it's it's an epsilon potential yeah but
this is no longer an equilibrium
okay the only aquarium is here but all
the dynamics that are good for potential
will still be
approaching this set okay and i think
and this is good this goes back to the
talk of probably
the
last workshop
uh
i don't know why
when you are looking at dynamics
concerning a behavior in games it should
converge to a point
there's no reason for me it can
oscillate
it will be stable here you have a good
attractor but it's not so the same other
side is stable but it's not the
collection of dashonic
okay
and so this is your question when you
are close to
yeah i guess
but it may be very very different yeah i
guess uh what i was getting at is that
i guess maybe that's for uh uh offline
discussion but like
there are
deviations from dissipativeness
that can be exploded to create dynamics
that actually do converge to equilibria
and if you care about equilibria they
give you a way to get there
uh
yeah i guess the question of like do we
want equilibrium the first place is a
different question so
then a bigger question so
maybe let's continue that offline if
there are any other questions uh please
uh let me know or are there any in the
chat uh no okay
all right
no okay let's let's like sylvan again
thank you